today on the matt welsh show democrats
spend a day in congress censoring and
condemning a republican for posting an
offensive cartoon meme to his twitter
page aoc's aoc says that anyone who
doesn't share in their outrage is a
nihilist but who are the real nihilists
here also the daily wire scores a major
victory as osha suspends the biden vaxx
mandate and huge record numbers of
people are dying of drug overdoses 100
000 people died last year why is it
happening what's going on plus an msnbc
host
wants us to warn us about the scourge of
quote-unquote white tears what does that
mean besides that she's racist and a
doctor says that he still can't take his
three-year-old to the grocery store
without feeling like he's risking her
life how can people especially doctors
still be that deluded we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
say what's easier than opening a can of
cranberry sauce
getting free insurance quotes from
policy genius policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place why
compare well you could save 50 or more
on life insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genes you could save 1300 or
more a year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies the
licensed experts of policy genius work
for you not the insurance companies so
you can trust them to help you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of service has earned
policy genius thousands of five-star
reviews across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy that uh swaps the
standard medical exam requirement for a
single phone call
this exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes advisor higher than
options from ladder ethos and bestow
getting started is very easy first you
just gotta head to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much life
insurance coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price
and uh they don't add any extra fees
it's very easy to do very cheap so
there's no reason not to head to
palsygenius.com to get started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right as it stands
right now we continue to wait for the
written house verdict it's extremely
troubling that it's taken so long
troubling because we have to remember
something really basic here the standard
is supposed to be reasonable doubt and
it can be
easy to forget this it can be easy to
forget as we watch a trial
that's been rigged in every way against
the defendant
it's easy to forget that in fact trials
are supposed to be in a way you might
say rigged in favor of the defendant
rigged is not really the right right
word here of course the point is just
that the defendant is supposed to be
given a head start there are certain
advantages that are meant to be
built into the system that's how the
system is is made and one advantage is
that the prosecution needs to prove its
case while all the defense needs to do
is establish that there is maybe
reasonable doubt about what the
prosecution has claimed
and that is is supposed to be anyway um
a pretty low standard it's meant to be
the defense doesn't need to prove that
the the defendant is innocent all they
need to demonstrate is that it's
reasonable to doubt
whether he is guilty
just that it's reasonable
and they don't even actually need to
demonstrate it the prosecution has to
demonstrate that it is not reasonable to
doubt the defendant's guilt if they fail
to meet that purposefully high bar then
that's supposed to be game over that's
the way it's supposed to work
so we've gotten into the weeds quite a
bit in this case uh we've talked about
you know the specifics and all the
things surrounding it but uh questions
like uh should he have been there or not
and you know i've said about i think he
had not only had every right to be there
but um
but it was good that some people showed
up to actually defend the property if if
the government had decided that it was
not going to fulfill that role which it
had decided that but most of that should
be a moot point the only thing that
matters is this could a reasonable
person
have at least some doubt about whether
kyle riddenhaus is guilty of murder
could a reasonable person entertain the
possibility at least
that kyle rittenhouse acted in
self-defense
the answer to that question is obviously
yes
it would be unreasonable to say that it
is unreasonable to have doubts about
this case
i think there's a lot more than
reasonable doubt in this case i think
rather than guilty beyond reasonable
doubt in fact he is innocent beyond
reasonable doubt but that's not the
standard
that's not the burden that he's supposed
to have to carry as a defendant and we
should keep that in mind but while we
wait for this verdict something else
happened yesterday worth discussing
right here in the opening i think from
yahoo news
they report quote the house voted
wednesday to censure representative paul
gosar after the arizona republican
posted a violent cartoon video that
depicted him killing representative
alexandria casa cortez and attacking
president biden the resolution passed
223 to 207 with two republicans
representative liz cheney and adam
kissinger of course
joining all 221 democrats voting in
favor of gosar censure representative
dave joyce who sits on the house ethics
committee voted present
three republicans did not vote
the measure stripped gosar of his
committee assignments including a seat
on the house oversight committee a panel
which he had served on which he had
served alongside ocasio-cortez
okay so this is um what the house of
representatives concerned itself with
yesterday all right and and many
democrats took turns giving impassioned
speeches discussing in somber and and
firm tones the inexcusable violent
threatening dangerous terrible meme that
paul gosar retweeted
before we go any further
we should probably play that uh meme for
you
just so you understand what we're
talking about
it is a jokey video apparently made as a
as a parody based on some kind of anime
show i'm not familiar with the show
and uh it shows gosar as some kind of i
don't know action hero ninja or
something
and at one point in the cartoon well
rather at one point a cartoon with
gosar's face attached hits another guard
cartoon
with aoc's face attached with a sword
okay very dangerous stuff
parental advisory stickers all over this
thing but let's uh let's just give it a
watch
[Music]
my god horrifying
that's the worst thing i've ever seen in
my life
so while inflation skyrockets cargo
ships remain jammed in our ports drug
epidemic kills 100 000 americans a year
dozens of other very real crises grip
our nation congress spent the day
talking about uh this cartoon
and nancy pelosi kicked things off
shaking her head saying that this is a
sad day it's a sad sad day for congress
and she's right actually it is a very
sad day for congress but not for the
reason she thinks
and she continued by drawing a
connection to
what do you think she connected this to
you just take a guess january 6th of
course she said quote depictions of
violence can foment actual violence and
jeopardize the safety of elected
officials as witnessed in this chamber
on january 6 2021 it is inconceivable
that a member of our community would
wish to repeat the violence of that dark
day
now we're not going to test our
intestinal for fortitude by playing too
many clips of these democrats sobbing
over a meme cartoon on twitter but we do
have to play at least i think we have to
at least suffer through a little bit of
aoc's remarks
because she after all was the victim
the quote unquote victim of this cartoon
and that is an udder that she is always
eager to milk and let's watch her do
that now
i've been serving in this body
just under three years
not three years
enormous amount has happened
but in response to
the republican leader's remarks when he
says that
this action is unprecedented
what i believe is unprecedented
is for a member of house leadership
of either party
to be unable to condemn
incitement of violence
against a member of this body
it is sad
it is a sad day
in which a member who leads a political
party in the united states of america
cannot bring
themselves to say
that issuing a depiction of murdering a
member of congress is wrong
and instead
decides to venture off into a tangent
about gas prices and inflation
what is so hard
what is so hard
about saying that this is wrong
this is not about me
this is not about representative gosar
but this is about what we are willing to
accept
this is not about me
this is not about me as i use the word
me and i
uh 72 times in my 10-minute speech about
me
yeah we really can't on second thought
we should not be playing clips of uh
alexandria case or cortez when we are
broadcasting from
you know the uh the sixth floor of a
hotel room where i'm when i'm right next
to a window because the urge to jump out
is sometimes overwhelming when i'm
listening to this person a sad sad day a
sad day an incitement of violence
democrats of course are not satisfied to
call the cartoon merely inappropriate or
crass or vulgar
no they have to make it into a terrorist
act they have to pretend that gosar was
actually threatening himself
he was himself threatening to stab aoc
with a sword or encouraging other sword
wielding assailants
this meme was actually a message to
gosar's team of secret ninjas calling on
them to finally launch their
long-planned attack
that's the way democrats tried to
present it and when most republicans
aside from the usual suspects cheney
kinzenger uh refused to join the censure
that sent them into even more furious
spasms of outrage aoc accused
republicans of nihilism for uh not being
angry enough about the twitter meme
and all the democrats were very upset
pretending to be very upset anyway uh
the republicans would not would not join
wouldn't it would not join them in being
that upset
but republicans were right of course to
not go along with this why i mean is it
because congressmen ought to be
posting with anime memes you know is
that is that is that a is that a thing
ideally that we'd be doing no i mean it
doesn't bother me personally i think
it's kind of funny but in a in a perfect
world
it would not be unreasonable to say yeah
you know that's a little inappropriate
it's kind of crash and childish let's
not do that you know
yet in this world which is far from
perfect
even if you feel that way about the meme
you can't say it would democrats demand
that you say you can't bark on command
like a trained puppy because then you
are willfully participating in a charade
you are assuming a role in their stage
play
aoc called it nihilism that republicans
will not condemn
inappropriate behavior that's not what's
going on here
it's more that they are refusing to be a
part of the democrats nihilism
if the democrats in congress actually
cared about incitements of violence
and about crass and inappropriate
behavior by its members
and they condemned every such example
and they were so stringent about it so
respectful of the rules of decorum and
decency that they even made time to
condemn memes and cartoons right
if this was all in the context of them
being very consistent on this issue then
maybe you might give them a little bit
of what they want you might say sure
yeah you shouldn't opposed to that
but that's not how it works
their message is not that members of
congress should not incite violence
um not that paul gosar did incite
violence but that's not their message
their message the point they want
republicans to agree with
as they all clasp hands together is that
the rules should be applied based on
their ideological and political needs of
the moment
which is why for example when maxine
waters has repeatedly and explicitly
called for violence against her
political enemies or squad members
repeatedly and explicitly justify and
foment blm writing
there's no condemnation there certainly
no censure
because the rules are different for them
and anyone who will not agree that the
rules are different
is a nihilist they say
it's all quite grotesque and outrageous
which is why republicans need to do a
lot more than simply refuse to go along
with it that's a good first step so
there's a little bit of progress here
um because i think if this exact same
situation had occurred like five years
ago uh there probably would have been
you know 30 republicans joining
at least so they're not going along with
it that's good
but they should also be on the on the
offense
using the bully pulpit to call attention
to
behavior on the other side that often
goes far beyond memes and cartoons just
the latest example representative cory
bush like we talked about on this show
this week called a defendant in a murder
trial a white supremacist without any
evidence she's of course not the only
one to have done that
and also without evidence claim that
white supremacists shot at her in uh in
the streets of ferguson which we know is
a lie it never happened
why aren't republicans moving to censure
cory bush for that
sure they don't have the votes
but they can call for it anyway
two can play at that game but only one
ever does
i think it's time for that to change
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well living your everyday life is
getting more and more expensive as i'm
sure you've noticed and so here's here's
maybe the smartest move you'll make all
year and there's time to do it now at
the 11th hour make your smart move might
be the only smart move you make in the
entire year if you're me a mortgage
refinance could be the smartest move it
could save you thousands of dollars in
interest maybe help pay off your loan
sooner or even allow you to access cash
but to really capitalize on a mortgage
refinance you must be sure you're
choosing the right loan with the right
lender that's why i recommend american
financing america's home for home loans
for over 20 years they've been a
mortgage industry leader offering
competitive rates low monthly payments
and custom terms without ever charging
upfront or hidden fees you get a free
mortgage review and you'll also learn
about ways to save up to a thousand
dollars a month if you give them a call
you may even be able to skip two
mortgage payments but you've got to call
american financing right now and you've
got to do it as i said right now 866 569
4711 that's 866-569-4711
or visit americanfinancing.net
um
by the way i want to mention that just a
quick shout out to uh the member of the
sweet baby gang that i encountered at a
deli here in nashville
and yeah i went to a couple days ago i
went to delhi he got a sandwich and
um he handed me the sandwich back we
have the picture here he had the he
handed me this the sandwich back um and
he had written on the rapper the
sandwich sweet baby he didn't say
anything to me you know never
acknowledged that he even knew who i was
he wrote sweet baby gang on the rapper
now the thing is he handed that to me
and um i didn't i didn't notice what was
written on it initially because i don't
notice anything i'm like lost in my own
head you can ask my wife i don't i don't
notice anything around me i'm totally
oblivious i mean she could uh she always
makes changes in the house and i come
home i don't notice it like she could
replace all of our furniture with
balloon animals or something and i and i
i wouldn't notice she could set
i could be sitting on the couch and she
could set it on fire while i'm sitting
on it i probably wouldn't notice
um
so i didn't notice that but i went in to
go pay for it at the cashier
and that's when i noticed it because he
called attention to we both kind of
noticed it together and he had no idea
what that meant and he was very very
confused and a little bit disturbed and
he read it and he's and he said uh sweet
baby gang huh
and i said oh yeah
yeah and then there was a little bit of
an awkward pause and he said do you mind
if i ask what that means
and then i just leaned in and i kind of
whispered i said you don't want to know
and i left it at that and it was even
more awkward for the re and we we
finished the checkout in total silence
and i walked out and it was great so
appreciate that for the sweet baby gang
um okay
i want to talk about this osha thing but
before we do that one other
uh
one other point going back to the to the
opening because i don't want to
i don't want to neglect to play this
this clip i talked about republicans
going on the offense well
credit where it's due lauren bobert
she actually did that okay so she's
she's giving a little bit of a blueprint
here for what that might look like she
got up to talk during this discussion
this debate over censuring paul gosar
and she did something this this again
five years ago i don't think you're
going to see any republican doing this
but she did and it's great let's listen
democrat policies are so pathetic and
have done so poorly that the left has
nothing else to do patrol the internet
looking for ways to get offended and
then try to target members and strip
them of their committees this is a dumb
waste of the house's time but since the
speaker has designated the floor to
discuss members inappropriate actions
shall we
the jihad squad member from minnesota
has paid her husband and not her brother
husband the other one over a million
dollars in campaign funds this member is
allowed on the foreign affairs committee
while praising terrorists
a democrat chairwoman incited further
violence in the streets outside of a
courthouse and then the cherry on top
my colleague and three-month
presidential candidate from california
who is on the intelligence committee
slept with fang fang a chinese spy
let me say that again a member of
congress who receives classifieds
sleeping with the enemy this is
unacceptable and this would never
generate time to expire gentlemen from
florida
got to give that a standing ovation that
as as the kids say online where's the
lie everything she said is exactly
correct now the one
point i will make here okay in fairness
to swalwell she says cherry on top we
have no evidence and no reason to
believe
uh that he was on top and in fact
there's a lot of reasons to think
probably wasn't but that's that's aside
from the point he did in fact sleep with
with a chinese spy and
it's not actually funny it's one of
those things all you can all you can do
is laugh about it because we have a
member of congress who is in a sexual
relationship with a chinese spy
named fang fang and uh it's not an issue
that's i'm not going to censor we're not
going to talk about it
okay well just a member of congress in a
sexual relationship with a child with a
foreign with a foreign spy from a from a
from a foreign adversary
uh
ilhan omar
speaking of foreign adversaries uh iohan
omar was she responded to this
and
because she was called out there i mean
she you know had she was married to her
brother allegedly i'm not sure if we
still have to put allegedly on that or
not
um
beau bart says she's part of part of the
jihad squad
and ilhan omar responded on twitter she
says
luckily my dad raised me right otherwise
i might have gone to the floor to talk
about this insurrectionist who sleeps
with a pervert she's talking about
bobert now i'm grateful i was raised to
be a decent human and not a depraved
person who shamefully defecates and
defiles
the house of representatives
and then uh praise god
okay well first of all the people who
are defecating
you know
this
as far as defecating in uh in in you
know
important places i think that obviously
goes to joe biden there's no evidence
that lauren boyberd has ever done that
as far as her dad raising her rights you
know i will say
johann um i guess your dad raised you
and your husband very well
imagine the the arrogance of this person
of ilhan omar
and the bubble that she's in
that she would actually go down this
road of talking about
criticizing someone else for being
married to a pervert i'm not even sure
what she's referring to with bobert
there
but you're you are going to open that
door
of all people
amazing
all right
let's move to this this from fox it says
the occupational safety and health
administration osha
is abiding by a court order and
suspending enforcement of the biden
administration's coven 19 vaccine
mandate on large private businesses in a
statement shared to osha's website the
agency said the court ordered that osha
take steps take no steps rather to
implement or enforce
the mandate until further court order
the agency said that it remains
confident in its authority to protect
workers in emergencies but as it stands
right now
it has been suspended
so any employer who is enforcing
this mandate they have no excuse to
enforce it they don't have to
no one has
no one has to do anything no one is
under any obligation to do anything
legally because it has been
suspended um and this happens after the
daily wire
filed a lawsuit
so we are we're fighting back and we're
getting results
it's this is not the sexiest thing right
when you're filing a lawsuit
in federal court not not the sexiest
form of fighting back
but uh it's an effective form
and it matters
you know and we we talk about this
phrase fighting back and we hear it so
often
and often in reference to things that
are to you know just people tweeting and
doing totally impotent things that's
kind of lost its meaning
but this is real fighting and the thing
is you know i still talk to some people
on
occasion who say that their problem with
the daily wire
is that uh we don't
fight you know that's an impression that
among some people i think the minority
but it still seems to linger a little
bit with some people anyway and i find
that kind of amazing because what
conservative outlet and i know that i'm
biased
for obvious reasons but what
conservative outlet is doing more than
us that's a serious question
can you name one
any conservative outlet out there that's
doing more than we're doing
lots of other outlets
out there that i respect and i like and
i support and you should support too but
nobody's doing what we're doing
um we're suing the federal government
you know we help flip virginia
we are to use the the uh the liberal
term we're disrupting the entertainment
industry we're getting into
investigative journalism we've already
we've made a huge impact as far as
echoes
these are all things that we're doing
and i really believe that by the way i
wouldn't say it if i didn't believe it
i might i might say
yeah this isn't a promo spot i might say
things in promo spots that i don't
believe well theoretically i mean
everything i say in promo spots i mean
but theoretically that's one thing
uh but this is this is uh this is real
daily wire is a special place and i'll
tell you why because
we actually care about
the mission you know we we really do
actually care
uh we're we are crazy enough to care
and that's
you can't always take that for granted
that's not always the case
i'm not going to say any names or
anything really because i can't say
names i can't see it inside anybody's
head or inside their heart and soul but
just because there are people in front
of cameras
saying a lot of conservative sounding
things
and uh building an audience of
conservatives that doesn't mean that
they really believe what they're saying
or care that much about it
but in our case we really do
and putting our money where our mouth is
in a very literal sense
okay
next joy reid continues to put her
anti-white bigotry on full display i
know we're used to it by now right with
this woman but this is really even even
by her standards
this is over the top
let's listen
so it's car written house trial
it reminded a lot of people of something
something i just can't remember what it
was oh
the brett kavanaugh hearings in which
brett kavanaugh who had been accused by
a high school friend of committing
sexual abuse of her
cried his way through
the hearings to make him a permanent
member
and associate justice of the united
states supreme court
and his tears turned out to be more
powerful than the tears of christine
blasey ford which were the tears of an
alleged victim
but in america there's a thing
about both white vigilantism
and white tears
particularly
male white tears
really white tears in general because
that's what carrots are right they carry
out and then as soon as they get caught
green water works
[Music]
white men can get away with that too and
it has the same effect
even as
the right tries to politicize the idea
that masculinity is being robbed from
american men by multiculturalism and
wokism
they still want to be able to have their
tears
uh
okay can you believe it those damned
white people they uh they want to have
their tears what the hell does that mean
well i know what it means i'll get that
in a second but also notice the catch-22
here
and it was on full display in the in the
um kavanagh hearing that she brought up
also with written house because the
catch-22 is
that if you're a man
and you're accused of something be it
rape or murder
and you get up there
and you are calm and collected
and you address the charges against you
and you deny them
and you show very little emotion
then you're going to you'll be accused
of being some kind of
sociopath and we're going to hear a lot
about toxic masculinity so if you get up
there you're accused
and you're not emotional about it then
that is toxic masculinity you know
you're you're playing tough you're being
a sociopath you don't care you know you
should care you don't care enough you're
you're stuffing all the emotions inside
all this kind of stuff that's toxic
masculinity
but
if you get up there and you're emotional
then it's white male tears
so no matter what you do no matter what
your response is and it's designed this
way of course no matter how you respond
you are somehow proving that the
allegations against you are correct and
you are uh only only demonstrating your
your moral
failings literally no matter how you
respond
and that of course is because the people
like joy reid it doesn't
the moment you've been accused
you're guilty and in fact let me back it
up one step uh further
you're guilty before you're accused
enjoy you have to understand enjoy
reed's world
every white male is effectively a rapist
and a murderer
whether they've done it themselves
or not
they are part of a a system that is
guilty of these kinds of crimes and so
they themselves are personally guilty
and even if they haven't done it then
you know they're they're always a risk
to do it um so you know as far as joy is
concerned you throw kyle written house
in prison even if he's not technically
guilty of murder um you know he
basically is he's a white male he's part
of the system and and probably at some
point in the future he's gonna harm
someone uh so you might as well put him
in jail now kavanaugh you know again
same same kind of thing
he's he's as far as as far as joy reid's
concerned he he's
basically guilty even if not with with
the
with christine ford at some point i'm
sure he's done this or he will do it and
so let's he should be held accountable
for it regardless
and that's the catch 22. no matter how
you respond
you're guilty
because you're guilty before you respond
the conclusion has already been
determined
and therefore however you respond well
that's how a guilty person would respond
because you're guilty
there's the circular reasoning of it
but i also want you to understand
understand how
and i probably don't need to point this
out to you but really
reflect on how racist
this white tears thing is
i mean it's the most dehumanizing thing
i can imagine
she is suggesting essentially that as
white people
we don't have human emotions
we are not human it's it's all
manipulation
because if you saw white people as human
then kyle rittenhouse's response even if
you think he's guilty
his response makes a lot of sense even
if you're a guilty person
and you uh you know you killed someone
and you murdered them
and now you're now you're facing uh life
in prison any normal person guilty or
not would would have an emotional
breakdown at at least some point during
that process
if not multiple multiple emotional
breakdowns the whole way through
so that's that's a normal human response
guilty or not
what kind of person would see this is an
18 year old kid
accused of murder facing life in prison
his entire life this is this is the
reality that as he sits right now
waiting for the verdict
there is a distinct possibility that
that for the rest of his life which
could last
60s he could spend 70 years of his life
his entire life
in a cage
once again guilty or not who who would
not
have a an emotional breakdown a panic
attack cry
when faced with that
and yet joy reid
sees that and she's suspicious she's
suspicious because he's a white male and
she doesn't think that white males or
even white people in general have
emotions
it is uh i mean she
lots of people in positions of influence
in this country today and power
really truly hate white people
truly hate them
she hates them
and i'll tell you this there is no one
and i really mean no one
in a position of power or influence in
this country today who truly hates black
people in the way that joy reid hates
white people and we know that because
those kinds of people those kinds of
races
have been driven out they were long ago
driven out this is a very intentional
campaign
to find the racists and drive them out
but only certain kinds of races right
but racists like joy reid you know
they're that's fine you can do that
we we you know there's there's not going
to be any segment i don't care anyone on
the left you think fox news is racist
which it isn't but
you think you're ever going to see a
segment on fox news
there's a black murder defendant is
there going to be someone on fox news
talking about the problem of black tears
it's it's quite literally unimaginable
it would never ever happen
and um
that's because this kind of out and out
this is dangerous i mean when you've got
people in positions of influence joy
reid should have no influence whatsoever
she's not qualified to hold any job at
all but she she does have influence and
when you have this kind of
totally dehumanizing
racism
against you know
this this effort to dehumanize an entire
race of people it is very dangerous and
it's it's it's not going
well it's going in the same to the same
place and heading in the same direction
that these sorts of things always do
throughout history
all right um this is from upi.com says
new government data confirms what many
have suspected
the pandemic has prompted a record
number of drug overdose deaths with more
than a hundred thousand americans
succumbing to addiction as cova-19 rage
across the country that figure is almost
30 times higher than pre the previous
year when 78 000 overdose deaths were
reported according to provisional
figures from the u.s center for disease
control
um
lead researcher on on this says the
12-month period ending in april 2021 is
the first time we've seen over a hundred
thousand estimated deaths due to drug
overdose
drug overdose deaths continue to rise at
least through april 2021 so this past
spring
and um that's this past spring we
haven't seen any indication that the
numbers are slowing down so
it's actually worse than this this is
just until the spring
and as he said there's no reason to
think
that it's gotten better a hundred
thousand people dying of a drug overdose
in one year hundred thousand
okay you don't have to go back that far
to what a point when the number would
have been something like thirty or 40
000 or 50 000 which was still a lot
it's doubled now and in a short period
of time what does that tell us well this
is something we could spend a lot more
time on it maybe we will in a different
show but on a future show
a few things here first of all
as many of us said the entire time
lockdowns
okay
lock the the lockdown is not a it's not
a victimless situation
okay
it's not just a matter of um well better
safe than sorry let's play it safe and
do this and uh and um you know
even if we're inconveniencing people at
least we're preventing people from dying
no there are victims of the lockdown
the lockdown is something that you're
doing and it will it will it will itself
cause deaths and it has this is drug
overdose it's not a coincidence that
this even the cdc is not denying that
there's a connection between the
lockdowns and drug overdose deaths
uh we know about suicide and and uh you
know the the rapidly
dramatic increase in suicide deaths and
suicide attempts especially among kids
that happened during the lockdown
so this was a
this was a calculation that was made
saying that let's lock everybody down
and we're going to do that in order to
theoretically save the lives of this
group over here
but in so doing we're going to ensure
that this group over here dies so it's
kind of it was a trade a trade-off
and not a trade-off worth making
also another point is that it's really
unfortunate that criticizing the
pharmaceutical industry is now an
anti-science conspiracy theory
i mean this used to be something where
you would find some common ground this
was actually an issue
up until covid
this was an issue where there was uh
some amount of common ground between the
left and right
that we could talk about the
pharmaceutical industry and abuses in
the pharmaceutical industry and the way
that the pharmaceutical industry has
very intentionally gotten millions of
people hooked on um on opioids and other
drugs and we could talk about that and
you know you could find
agreement on the left and right but now
after covet in the vaccine
it's been decided that in order to
protect and defend the honor of the
vaccine that means we also have to
protect and defend the honor of the
pharmaceutical industry
and so criticizing pharmaceutical
industry now has become
it's now a partisan thing
uh and uh and if you do that it's it's
sort of an anti-science conspiracy
theory
which is really a shame
because when we talk about a hundred
thousand overdose deaths
and it's not gonna get better on its own
it's only gonna get worse
big part of the blame yeah we have
lockdowns
also pharmaceutical industry uh as i
said the pharmaceutical industry has
very intentionally
gotten millions of people hooked on
drugs
and this is all part of the as i said
it's a much bigger conversation that we
probably should spend more time on but
this is all part of a problem i've
talked about on the show which is the
the medicalizing of the human condition
everything is a medical problem now
um everything can there's a drug for
everything
every uncomfortable feeling that you
feel go get a drug for every every uh
pain that you that you experience every
physical pain go get a drug for it
and and there's of course you you can't
watch tv without seeing these
advertisements
for for um
for drugs these pharmaceutical
advertisements
and what they're doing they're not
they're not simply saying you know that
they're they aren't in these in these
advertisements they are not just selling
the drug they're also selling the
disease
they say to you in in the advertising
well are you experiencing this in this
uh
symptom well then you might have this
disease and hey by the way here's the
drug for it
that's that's not the way that this
really should work
and it and historically it hasn't worked
that way
i mean historically traditionally you go
to the doctor and you tell them your
symptoms
and they diagnose you and tell you what
the disease might be what the problem
might be and if there's a need for a
drug they'll give it to you
but now people have the pharmaceutical
industry
selling them the disease
and then they go to their doctors with
the disease already in mind with the
diagnosis that they got from an
advertisement or from webmd
and they bring that to the doctor and
they say this is the disease that i have
here are my symptoms here's the drug
give it to me and quite often they find
doctors who are
lacking in scruples and uh
have conflicts of interest financially
and are willing to do it so all of this
plays into it also we've got the border
wide open that's where all the fentanyl
is coming from and we've got a
you know an even deeper problem in our
culture of a loss of meaning and despair
and people are turning to drugs all
these things all together contribute to
this problem
all right
one other thing i wanted to play for you
before we get to uh reading the comments
netflix has a new show coming out and
this looks really um
innovative and unique we've never seen a
show like this before so i want to play
this for you check this out
the last 48 hours have been insane i'm
about to be put in the house with seven
other people that i've never met before
of course i gotta bring my whole closet
one of my goals is to step outside my
comfort zone to explore who i am
and just like that we're off oh i was
going the wrong way this whole time gas
station stop one of the few places i
actually will poop
the countdown to austin begins
this experience is going to help me grow
my wings i'm about to pull up to the
house i'm super nervous can we skip to
the good part
[Music]
okay well so it's the real world i the
only reason i play that
so netflix has discovered the real world
and
can you imagine like it's oh i would i
wouldn't suggest watching it but
it would almost be worth watching just
the first 20 minutes and i'll tell you
why
can you imagine how
insufferable
uh
a a show like the real world is going to
be now in the woke era
and these reality shows were bad enough
on their own
now add wokism into it i can't even i
guarantee first 20 minutes
they're having a difficult conversation
about race in the first 20 minutes i
guarantee it and also pronouns
at least they're getting outside of
their comfort zones you know and growing
their wings by living in a nice house in
austin with other attractive people who
all have the same values and opinions as
them so that's good i mean they're
really expanding the horizon so that's a
that's a one advantage here
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
all right
valve is better says matt thoughts on
forced monkey labor uh i'm totally for
it i think it's i think it's a great use
for monkeys and i know that in some in
some countries i guess they they do
they do use forced monkey labor i was
reading an article recently about i
don't know which country but i think
they use
uh monkeys for
maybe we've talked about this on the
show before this sounds like the kind of
thing we would talk about they use
monkeys for harvesting coconuts um
because it's hard to get the coconuts
all the way up in the trees and uh and
it is also dangerous to send a person up
there they could fall so you uh you just
you enslave the monkeys and you have
them go get the coconuts and uh you
don't have to pay them right that's the
great thing
and um and i think it's fantastic i mean
i think there should be more
any time there's like a dangerous job
like that
and there's not a lot of money to pay
someone to do it
and you can use animal labor um
then then yeah of course what's the
problem with that
of course in our in our silly mind and
we've been infected by disney and and
all that kind of thing so
we have this hierarchy in our mind of
the in the animal world
and a lot of people some people do of
course but most people don't have a
problem with the idea of barnyard
animals who are enslaved
uh but
doing that to a monkey oh they're
monkeys they're cute
i think it's fantastic i think it's a
really good idea
um
and you know something else
it gives the monkey
a purpose
i i think that that this this is the
most this is the greatest purpose that
you can give in animals to is to live in
service of a human being this is why i
think um some people don't like zoos i
think zoos are great
and you might look at the animal in the
zoo and feel sorry for the animals but
but uh but
this is their purpose they're bringing
joy and happiness to human beings um
kids are learning about animals isn't
that a great purpose for an animal to
serve
just to serve mankind
what's wrong with that you could feel
sorry for the elephant in the zoo
otherwise or they could be out
in their natural environment and they'll
die a lot sooner and you know they're
just kind of wandering around and um i i
think
to to be there
for the purpose of human be to be used
by human beings is a is a great and
wonderful purpose for animals and so
we're doing a favor for them
as well as ourselves
all right
pk877 says matt if britney spears was
really such a potential threat to
herself and others
how could they allow her to continue to
be a full-time pop star releasing
multiple albums and performing all over
the world making millions for the people
put in charge of her finances
yeah i don't um
i don't really buy that argument
you know as i said i don't know
britney spears a psychological state i
don't think you do you do either but i
do know that just because you can
perform on stage it doesn't that doesn't
say anything at all
about your psychological fitness
and your mental competence one way or
another
and i don't see why it would
yeah you can dance around on stage and
sing a song that doesn't mentally
incompetent people can do that as we as
we have seen uh through the years
um if by the way if they couldn't then
there wouldn't be any pop music there
wouldn't be a pop industry
another comment says ten minutes ago
matt walsh
there is no justice in our court system
it's all pageantry and can't be trusted
flash forward 10 minutes talking about
british spears matt walsh the decision
of the court should be taken at face
value and have the unquestioning power
to take over someone's life
okay
but that's not what i'm saying okay i'm
i'm asking where's the evidence of
britney spears's sanity
i'm i
it's that's a sincere question
i'm not the one who started the free
britney spears movement but if you're
going to be involved in that movement
saying she needs to be free from her
conservative then i would assume you
must have some evidence
that the claim that she's mentally
incompetent and a danger to herself and
others is untrue and if you don't have
that evidence then what the hell are you
doing calling for you
i mean would you walk into a mental
asylum and just point to some random
person and say i don't think they should
be here
maybe they shouldn't be there but do you
have any reason to think they shouldn't
that's all i'm saying here so if i went
up to you and i said um pretend i wasn't
talking about britney spears pretend i
was talking about someone named i don't
know bernice
spears and i said hey bernice was put
under a conservative ship because um
she's been judged mentally unfit and a
danger to herself and others would you
automatically say hey no way bernice
shouldn't be under that conservatorship
and if you did i would say well why do
you say that do you know anything about
the situation
of course the difference here is that
people think
because they they grew up watching
britney spears and they see her
performing
um and maybe they follow her on social
media they think they know her
and this is this this it's an illusion
that is totally an illusion that is
created
hollywood the the music industry the
record industry
they create the illusion
that you know these people
and that you're friends and that you're
all you know that they're a part of your
life
but they're not you don't know anything
about them at all
it's hard enough to know people that you
that
that are around you physically i mean
your next door neighbor
you probably don't even know them
and that's someone that you actually
talk to and can have conversations with
even there it's very difficult to say
that you know someone but a pop star you
don't know the first damn thing about
her you know nothing
unless you do in which case i'd love to
see what information you have but i've
never seen
um
let's see
meredith says i think i expected to be a
much better parent than i am but turns
out that being tired all the time
prevents some of that
one thing i have changed my mind on is
always answering the question why
my son loves testing boundaries also we
underestimate the corruption of a
grandparent who wants to spoil
yeah this is one thing again non-parents
you'll hear that um i hear this
criticism and from people and i always
know they're non-parents when they say
this
but they say that um
because i said so is you you should
never answer a child with because i said
so that's a bad response you know it's
because we should take the kids
seriously and always answer their
questions and no matter how many
questions they they they ask we should
always be ready to sit there and have a
conversation well i'll tell talk to you
about this
um but no i think i think in fact
because i said so is not only an
appropriate response but it's a
necessary response and it's and it's
it's um children need to hear that
there's an important lesson in the
because i said so
meaning that
i am the parent and you should respect
me and listen to me
now that doesn't mean
that you should unquestioningly listen
to everyone who claims to be an
authority figure forever
but as a child you need to have respect
for your elders
and there are going to be things they
tell you
that you're not going to understand but
you should still listen because they
know more than you do
and so we as the adults we don't have to
convince you to to do as you're told
okay the this is not a situation where
um
we have to wait around for you to
understand it
and then you'll listen
no you need to do it because you're told
that's a really important lesson for
kids and that that
my test here my litmus test is um if the
why question is asked
sincerely
then i'll do my best to answer it
but oftentimes with kids it's a form of
defiance
you say go clean your room and they go
why why well they don't that's not a
that's not a serious inquiry
that's their way of saying i don't want
to do it buzz off old man
and that's when you drop the because i
said so
i'm not gonna give you a whole
dissertation on why it's better to have
the room clean and blah blah blah
i'm the dad i told you to do it now do
it
um
you have another thing that we learn as
we become parents i gotta tell you again
about get upside app i know there's
there many many of my listeners have
taken advantage of this and gone out and
gotten you got the app but but if you
haven't i mean what are you waiting for
all you gotta do is go go on your phone
right now and uh go to google play or
the app store wherever and get the get
upside app because it's all upside
you're going to make 25 cents for every
gallon of gas every time you fill up
just download the free github site app
in the app store or google play right
now use promo code walsh and get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first philip
that's up to 50 cents cash back
don't pay full price of the pump anymore
get cash back using the get upside app
just download the app for free it is
again free and use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cashback on
your first tank some people who drive a
lot are making as much as 2 or 300 or
more a month in cash back and there's no
catch it really is as simple as that the
cash gets added right to your account
and how do you get the cash out well
it's just they send it to your bank
account they send it to they can give it
to you through paypal
they can give you an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands it really is
that easy and with all the money that
we're spending on gas prices groceries
and everything else if you've got an
opportunity to save some money and make
make money back then you can't afford to
not do it so just download the free get
upside app and use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cashback on
your first tank that's code walsh i
can't believe i have to tell you this
again but if you're listening to my show
and you still haven't subscribed to my
newsletter you're making a huge mistake
because not only are you
frankly hurting my feelings
okay i don't want to shed any white male
tears i'm not going to do that but it
does hurt my feelings
but uh also you're you know you are
depriving yourself of the opportunity
to win
something probably the most special gift
that you'll certainly that you'll that
you'll uh have all year including the
upcoming christmas season you don't even
you don't even need christmas if you win
this gift because your subscription to
the newsletter will automatically enter
you into the running to claim the banjo
which sits behind me in the studio
guarded faithfully by uh by our friendly
alien in the back of the of the studio
um this is a banjo that i have spent
many many hours playing and you can own
it yourself and then that banjo will
then be not that i not that i will uh
not that not that any banjo can really
be replaced but my my old banjo will
then take its rightful place so this is
a this is sort of a passing of the banjo
baton and if you want to be a part of
this sacred process then head to
dailywire.com banjo to subscribe to my
newsletter and um you'll get the
newsletter once a week and you'll also
be entered to win the banjo so do that
right now dailywire.com banjo now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we're going to cancel dr jorge
caballero
now i will confess that i struggled a
little bit with this cancellation i
wasn't sure if i wanted to spend a whole
cancellation on dr jorge given that his
offense is so commonplace and has been
covered so many times
on this show that it feels a little
redundant redundant but as should be
clear by now the determining factor for
who makes it on the daily cancellation
is not the importance of the issue
or even the entertainment value it's
just simply who has most recently
annoyed me
and given that um i saw this tweet from
dr jorge this morning and uh he has made
the cut
and there are a couple things here that
really push push him over the top i
think and we'll uh we'll we'll get into
that so dr jorge is a physician with a
relatively large following on social
media whose bio says come for the facts
stay for the snark and of course
includes a hashtag
uh black lives matter the real m night
shyamalan sort of twist ending here is
that he doesn't have his pronouns listed
in his bio i'm sure i'll get around to
that i hope he does actually get around
to it because we are rapidly approaching
a point where anybody who doesn't list
their pronouns is a transphobe by
default we might already be there in
fact
so in any case a couple days ago dr
jorge tweeted this
he said i would like to go into a
grocery store with my three-year-old and
not have to feel like i'm risking his
life or her life
is that too much to ask
i'd like to go to grocery store with my
three-year-old and not have to feel like
i'm risking her life is that too much to
ask
but wait there's more many of the
comments responding to the good doctor's
paranoid ramblings were all in agreement
commiserating with him a quick sample
tracy says i shudder when i see two
parents taking their unmasked less than
five-year-olds into a store
what are they thinking
and brooks says two of my three kids
have not been in a store or restaurant
in nearly two years honestly i feel like
my mental health will never recover from
finding out how awful the majority of
americans are about all of this
well i agree with you there actually i
think we're on the same page marta says
so it would seem for now so it would
seem for now my five-year-old does not
remember the inside of places
jennifer says i hear you was in a target
today in watertown massachusetts barely
any masks i was livid
could feel my blood boiling however when
i shop in grocery stores in newton
massachusetts almost everyone is masked
it's so so hard
another comment says we're in full gear
when we go into public it's just the way
we do it wouldn't it be nice if we
didn't have to and a guy named eric says
our 19 month old has never even been in
a store i feel i fear he'll be too big
to sit in the front of the cart by the
time it's safe for him to go grocery
shopping with me
and dr jorge responded to that one in a
follow-up tweet writing i feel this in
my soul cribs kids grow up so fast it
feels like the list of things that i'll
never get to experience with my daughter
grows longer by the day
now as i said
we have seen this sort of thing many
times already
but here's what sent it over the edge
for me
dr jorge's username
his twitter handle
is this i'm gonna make i'm not making
this up it is
data driven md
yes he is the data driven md he is
driven by the data which is why he feels
that he'd be risking his daughter's life
by potentially exposing her to a virus
that has a
99.999 survival rate for for kids her
age
and that actually overstates the risk to
her it's not that when she goes to a
grocery store that there's a you know a
point zero zero one percent chance that
she'll die
no point zero zero one percent is the
risk of death if she contracts the virus
but what are the chances that she'll
contract it
children her age have a very small
chance of even contracting the virus in
the first place added to the fact that
most of the adults that she encounters
are vaccinated added to the fact that at
a grocery store she's not having
sustained close quarters contact with
anybody
added to the very minuscule lethality of
the virus for her age group and for most
every age group by the way
run the calculations with all of those
percentages taken into account
and her risk of covet death from going
to the grocery store is much much much
much smaller than point zero zero one
percent
i wager that it's something like you
know point zero zero zero
zero zero zero one percent though even
that is probably a gross overestimation
and this risk
a risk so vanishingly tiny as to be
effectively non-existent
has the data-driven md paralyzed with
fear
the data has driven him insane it would
seem
except it's not the actual data that has
done that to him if this data these
numbers could incapacitate him to that
extent then certainly he would never
drive a car
the car trip to the grocery store is
vastly more dangerous for both himself
and his daughter than the grocery store
itself
he would never ride an elevator or an
airplane or cross a bridge
he'd never go inside any building for
fear of roofs caving in and floors
collapsing
he'd also never go outside for fear of
falling trees lightning strikes
if a point zero zero etc more zeros one
percent chance of death is too much to
bear
then life itself is too much to bear
these kinds of risks are built into
literally everything you do everywhere
all the time no matter what
sometimes the risks are much larger
i wonder if dr jorge has ever been on a
roller coaster
roller coasters are pretty safe but your
chance of injury or death is definitely
greater than .001 percent
and meanwhile it's a totally unnecessary
frivolous activity that you're paying
money to participate in
has dr jorge ever been to the beach
again pretty safe but there are sharks
and riptides and accidental drownings
and you could avoid the beach your
entire life and still live a relatively
full and normal existence
yet i bet he goes to the beach
doesn't think about it has dr jorge ever
eaten at a restaurant i mean before
covent
food poisoning allergic reactions
choking
has you ever gone up for a hike in the
woods bear attacks falling limbs you
could get lost you could trip and break
your ankle
you could get assaulted by a crazy
drifter or or by bigfoot
did you know that did you know that your
chance of getting killed by bigfoot in
the woods
is not zero percent
nobody can say that it's zero percent
if you're worried about bigfoot and you
come to me and say i'm going to the
woods i'm worried that bigfoot um might
attack me do you think that could happen
i would have to say
yeah it could happen i mean it could
probably won't it's like really small
chance but it's not impossible
and given that uh dr jorge is worried
about point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent risks he's he's now in the realm
of having to worry about bigfoot
actually i don't wanna scare him but
even if you stay out of the woods
your chance of getting beaten to death
by bigfoot is still not zero percent i
mean technically speaking it's in the
realm of possibility that bigfoot could
break into your home right now as you
sit pummel you senseless
kill your dog set your house on fire
this could happen
the chance of that occurring is not zero
have you taken any precautions
what is your bigfoot home invasion
contingency plan
you don't have one what are you
anti-science
see these are all data points that the
data-driven md has not taken into
account it would seem that's because he
isn't driven by data so much as by
feelings
and he even says so remember he says i
would like to go to a grocery store with
my three-year-old and not have to feel
like i'm risking her life is that too
much to ask
which brings us finally to our answer
yes doc
it's too much to ask
it is too much to ask that you be able
to do something without feeling a
certain way about it it's too much to
ask us anyway
it's too much to ask the world
because we can't do anything about your
irrational feelings we can't control
that
it's too much to ask of us it's not fair
to us it's not fair that we should have
to do anything at all that we should
have to in any way whatsoever account
for adjust ourselves for work around
your totally unreasonable and paranoid
feelings
your feelings are your problem
they're also your child's problem sadly
and that's the real tragedy here i
frankly don't care if you want to huddle
yourself inside for the rest of your
life um that might work out pretty well
for the rest of society honestly
but i do care that you're doing this to
your child
who was cursed with an insane
psychologically abusive father through
no fault of her own
and that's why i really hope you do
something about those feelings
you do something
not us you
until then
you are canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day god speed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 21.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle we'll tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there
you